[Musica]
a
all
[Musica]
ho pochi minuti 15 allora io sono l'uomo
sbagliato nel momento sbagliato però il
luogo giusto e quindi fingo di sapere le
cose che mi devo uscire intanto io ho
due curiosità youtube ora il manager di
tumore nei soncinese a nizza
un'influenza l'air poi ha cinto italy
riceva sarà tutto così il mio discorso
che tu parli italiano però è fantastico
seconda domanda quindi parlerò in
italiano seconda domanda chi guadagna
meno di 12mila euro
wow siete pochi così chi guadagna meno
di 6mila euro
siete mantenuti perché siete giovani
quindi la maggioranza guadagna più di
12.000 euro quella entrata e ci sono
cittadini stranieri di origine straniera
ok pochi ok però alcuni figli di [ __ ]
a ok allora sono a casa
bene bene bene
sono come un [ __ ] dai tempi dei
vostri genitori o zii cugini quello che
mi sento un po pugliese un po barese un
po anche emilia romagna e molto anche
romagnolo ha fatto sette anni di vu
comprà bene
questi sono gli y 13 44 completo alizzo
allora vi ho fatto vivere toman porta di
bronzo stesso sogno
ok voi però non vedete il tempo bene
allora e avete fame vero perché tra un
po riva il pranzo quindi cerco di
velocizzare tom and porta di bronzo
stesso sogno porta di bronzo quello che
blocca le persone per tanti sogni
diversi ok io qui non sono ancora
arrivati c'era il presidente del teatro
qui è andato a mangiare a ditte di che
mi piacerebbe tornare
a a recitare sono comprati e la cultura
ha bisogno di essere esportata fuori
confine anche a livorno va bene anno
siamo a pisa
ho sbagliato opposto ok bene allora
quello spettacolo che avete visto dietro
che io non ho tempo
ricardo non aveva tempo da darmi da
portare perché ho portato tutta la parte
finale dei fondamentalismi
mi serviva mezz'ora 18 minuti 18 però
vuol dire volere fa soldi sviluppo in
questo momento di crisi aiuta e quindi
io vi racconto brevemente la mia storia
è piena di diseguaglianze
avete visto un vestito arlecchino o
arlecchino arlesheim traduttori di due
padroni quello che era dietro punti
persi italiano in cinesi che è il mio
vestito di scena principale
raccontandovi la mia esperienza di prato
non oso a fare lezioni di sociologo o
antropologi sono loro che interessa non
è perché sono un prodotto del italia di
oggi o della cina che si scontra con
l'italia di oggi
allora il titolo che mi stato assegnato
è i cinesi fanno quello che gli italiani
fan facevano una volta con tutte le sue
conseguenze
giusto ok la mia traduzione di questo
titolo che non saprei dire quali sono
state conseguenze sono tutto il corso
torrent con pink un corso lì a prato qui
in toscana
io non saprei dirvi esattamente se bari
una direzione di speranza o se no anche
ok e soprattutto davvero cinesi fanno
tutto quello che facevano gli italiani
una volta per me non tutto
non siamo esattamente uguali a voi una
volta io esattamente non sono [ __ ]
sono terrunciello chino bene la mia
traduzione del titolo di oggi dell'acm
intervento è non esistono diseguaglianze
e senza uguaglianza ha un concetto molto
triste io mi chiamo bianca
positivo ma non esisto senza in negativo
che non è il contrario negativo da
buttare via
attualmente esatto con quel segno cli fi
del centro dove c'è del bianco ed è
positivo ma contiene sempre un po di
diseguaglianze di negativo questo me lo
hanno insegnato i miei antenati e quindi
la mia traduzione di queste levante
sulla mia crisi di identità delle
seconde generazioni che è un processo in
corso chi sono
sul tema della pluralità delle
diseguaglianze dell'identità io qualcuno
mi riconosce per la strada come quello
dei n quello che è stato le invasioni
barbariche ma non sono quello sono anche
quello
io mi chiamo a differenza del nome che
ho fatto scrivere sopra è anche su
facebook
xi yan sci non gli annessi e basta
challant vuol dire pietra e sole
italiani mi chiamano young si e invece
ce ne sarebbe kakà di pecorara però ho
fatto pace con questa poi ripete ma io
ho fatto anni di analisi dalla mia
psicologa per fare pace con questo
perché cade di pecora è brutto me lo
dicevano da bambino io compilato i
moduli e mettiamo una freccia in alto
per dire che sono shiyan poi in teatro
si fa merde merde merde ho fatto pace
subito
ma il caffè di pecora comunque manca la
conoscenza dell'altro
qui parliamo di uguaglianza ma siamo
molto uguali pochi stranieri
pochi lo compra o chi veramente i ricchi
che guadagnano 50 di 50.000 o che
guadagnano meno di 6mila accedere a
bastad e va beh io parlo con voi
ho iniziato il discorso sul video col
nord del monologo che non faccio in
tempo a raccontarvi tutto ma vi racconto
brevemente e finirò un altro piccolo
video sulle uguaglianze tante facce che
sembrano disuguali che si trovano sullo
stesso posto di prato e sono forse anche
un po uguali ok cominciamo questa era la
premessa la mia casa vi porta qua che è
composto apparato qua siamo un teatro
molto importante
per voi pisani ma io vengo da una mia
casa di prato che si chiama con bus a
prato dove tu sei stato è un capannone è
grande quasi come questo palco e basta
ex lanificio e lì dentro abbiamo
ospitato tante iniziative
io conosco questa regione toscana più o
meno dal 2007 quando un altro un
progetto che si chiamava ppp politiche
potere forno grafia o altri accorrono mi
ho seguito due donne di teatro o sete
il tempo non si ferma quando avevo vero
va bene allora io ho conosciuto questo
posto cercando di studiare gli italiani
di oggi cosa che a me sinceramente non è
che pesa tantissimo nel 2007 mirò perun
diploma no volevo diplomarmi hanno
bocciato alla paolo grassi
avevo abbandonato la bocconi insomma era
un lavoro importante seguire queste due
donne dopo due anni di tournée e di
madre coraggio in tanti teatri dove
vedevo solo italiani e io a me non mi
interessava parlare solo italiani perché
la mia gente un milardo 4 anche i cinesi
e qui ci sono tanti vorrei parlare a la
mia gente e alla mia gente tante persone
sono tanti filippine tanti meridionali
di oggi del mondo di oggi del sud di
oggi comunque composta prato nasce da
alcuni presupposti di queste 90 artisti
del calibro anche di antonio tarantino
che intorno ad alcune sue intuizioni
parole chiavi tipo cadaveri culturali
non elaborati dell'italianità a ritroso
tangentopoli infatti abbiamo fatto certo
i lavori con anche grado colombo a
milano ed eccetera o piuttosto la falsa
coscienza di una certa sinistra tipica
che mi dava quasi più facile della
destra e poi comprendere le ragioni del
nemico che stai difficile soprattutto i
nemici si ritrovi dentro casa io mi
ritrovo tantissimi condomini di nemici
italiani cinesi cinesi cinesi italiani
italiani e anche restituire lo una
verità per intero bene in quel percorso
io ho cominciato a vedere le
disuguaglianze tra gli italiani
cominciando a capire forse un pochino
della vostra o nostra cultura
dal 2006 io sono cittadino italiano qui
vorrei raccontare a parte questo periodo
della casa mia di prato anche del
progetto sono qui perchè senza quella
non sarei qua nel 2012
c'è stato un anno di un progetto di
ascolto che mai se è stato fatto in
città a prato dove all'inizio eravamo
soltanto quindici persone che
ascoltavano cinque cinesi che parlavano
e c'era un cinese che ascoltava alla
fine dell'anno c'erano circa 3 400
cinesi e italiani di cui metà cinese
forse e c'erano italiani cinesi che
parlavano in questi dieci incontri i
termini che di cui si sono parlati sono
stati il lavoro le regole chi ruba
lavoro che la corresponsabilità che è
che guadagna gli affitti in nero e sta
zitto e spesso sono seconda generazione
di italiani e ci sono invece i cinesi
che una volta erano gli schiavi ed
adesso nei padroni e oggi sfruttano i
nuovi schiavi
e così via questo tutto così è
registrato vero tu auto censura è agli a
tagliar perché è vero che siamo in pochi
ma attraverso internet alcune cose non
sono molto comode anche in altri spazi
perché purtroppo tutto questo provoca
effetti nelle menti e nelle politiche di
altri posti
comunque tornando a questo progetto che
si chiama sono qui perché si sono fatti
dei giochi sociologici esattamente se
non sono stati fatti due dal titolo
visita prato o piuttosto dal titolo
ateniesi persiani spartani dove i atene
si facevano i pratesi e ai pratesi
facevano gli ateniesi i cinesi facevano
invece i persiani e le seconda
generazione tutte facevano gli spartani
così raccontato è molto difficile da
capire ma per via del tempo devo correre
allora noi stavamo per chiudere come un
gruppo per l'insostenibilità economica e
invece siamo dovuti andare avanti per il
fattaccio del primo dicembre 2013
dopo il quale abbiamo conosciute persone
come riccardo e dice a decidiamo di
rimanere e di non chiudere nonostante
invece i 300
mila euro circa investiti dal 90 persone
infatti adesso siamo rimasti tre e luca
lavora qui con la maschera ma anche
aiuto regista che portiamo a compimento
questo progetto che si chiama tom and in
questo spettacolo quello che avete visto
prima racconta nella prima parte la
storia dei miei antenati molti italiani
molti cinesi conoscono per esempio marco
polo e matteo ricci
nessun italiano sapete chi è 5 a 1 per
tu su di cinese però allora è brava
raccontano i tuoi amici era un eunuco
per esempio che era ha svolto un ruolo
come matteo ricci di portare la cultura
occidentale in cina facendo 30 anni
senza invadere comunque c'è molto da c'è
un gap una grande di varedo riempire
nella prima parte io racconta la storia
di ambiente nati in pratica ed alla mia
bisnonna al mio
la mia trisavola a il mio zio dauno
soprattutto la storia dei miei e di mio
nonno materno e di mio padre un pezzo
molto conflittuale come la quale sarà la
storia degli fascisti e dei partigiani
in casa vostra nella seconda parte
invece raccontano i mensili che ha 12
anni e lavare i piatti
sai te anni vivo compra ma ridendoci
sopra e alla fine elaboriamo questo e
l'urto del primo dicembre del 2013
quando appunto muoiono bruciati vivi
sette cinesi nella fabbrica di prato e
noi siamo testimoni di tutto questo
organizziamo i riti e portiamo in scena
quel lutto ma facendo ridere pubblico
speriamo e piangere e riflettere sui
fondamentalismi degli uni e degli altri
io chiedo una piccola deriva perché sono
un po in ritardo
però vorrei farvi un elenco del caos
quando uno è pieno di diseguaglianze
perché sono qui per questo per farvi
vedere come uno totalmente fuori luogo
nel tempo e nel contenuto
mi sento così in cina mi vedono come
straniero
qui mi vedono
straniero qui mi vedono come turista con
la riforma
io vorrei dire che sono italiano ma non
mi vedono anche se ci provo ed è molto
difficile e quindi vi chiedo tre minuti
di deroga in più così vi faccio vedere
il mio caos
cerco di sintetizzare innanzitutto
alcune domande che forse possa saltare
riguardano la geopolitica quale in
grande ma belle cito dal corriere della
sera se l'italia ha goduto delle fette
del piano marshall nel può seguirla cina
sta pianificando la sua di piano
marshall
non lo so altre domande di geopolitica
le democrazie in cina capitalismo di
stato o socialismo la cinese ma lasciamo
perdere
non lo so va bene non lo so ma so questa
è la rabbia che aiutata esce fosse non
riesco a controllarla ma su una serie di
cose che vi leggo allora nel buco di
prato vicino alla piazza del buco così
si chiama a prato piazza san marco in
via santa chiara 38 bar a 1 ma è a casa
mia composta nel 2012 o alla fine di 10
incontri è venuto fuori che il politico
di destra politico sinistro sono tutti
d'accordo che è grazie ai cinesi che
dopo 2008 distretto di prato non è
crollata dopo la crisi è un applauso e
cinese per favore perché consumano
perché comunque non fanno solo schiavi
de rendono anche del bene è che cacchio
lo dico da italiano più o meno
allora infatti li rispetta questa della
vostra toscana io sono a milanese vengo
da dell'expo l'irpet l'ha confermato nel
2014 due anni dopo questo dato va bene
secondo punto la toscana e culla del
rinascimento ma oggi non investe
abbastanza per innovare la sua le sue
culture non c'è soltanto alla cultura
telex c'è cultura ed extra ed è xilon
tevez eta e bla bla bla e non investe
abbastanza ma investe continuamente per
mantenere e conservare privilegi o
logica dei core orticelli burocrazia
logica dei diritti e sanità non
applaudite altro elenco dei chaos che
mia vita non ve li cito perché non
il tempo di entrare nel dettaglio e non
sono stato chiamato qui per come malika
a fare un pezzo di spettacolo allora è
pronto moda sono diversi dalle
confezioni
ok il pronto moda e lì dove si produce
il modo da portare in tutta europa
lo fanno i cinesi ma loro sono qua le
confezioni sono qua sono cosiddetti gli
schiavi che lavorano o che una volta gli
italiani facevano le confezioni
ok non fanno e non facevano impronta
moda l'hanno inventato e cinesi ma senza
usare il tessuto la lana degli italiani
chiuso il cinese he principe e anche
mendicante
così l'ho rubata della mia maestra
cristina pezzoli contemporaneamente è
padrone e schiavo chi ha comprato
pirelli e cinese chi sta comprando milan
e cinesi ma ehi schiavo dentro anche
nelle fabbriche ok e l'italiano cos'è e
servo e arlecchino contro l'irlanda non
lo so o non oso dire io sono harley
china un traduttore e traditore di due
padroni gli italiani da una parte e
cinese dall'altra sono un traduttore
simultaneo st mi parlano tanto allora e
c'è cassonetto e cassonetto nel 2009
quando abbiamo preso casa a prato
io sono rimasto molto colpito lei che al
braccialetto i capelli bianchi la
camicia bianca era un signore come l'ice
della sua età molto nella casa eto o è
che caccavo per abusato nel cassetto ma
non era quello giusto era passata da un
drone lamentale ho buttato una cosa
dentro è quella rabbia quella forza
quella violenta e mi ha fatto capire che
c'era qualcosa che non andava in quel
posto va bene
senz'altro anche responsabilità dei
cinesini ok
sui sette operai morti sono tutti
diversi hanno tutti un loro nome magari
non interessa a nessuno di voi
anch'io purtroppo non mi ricordo i loro
nomi sono molto difficili vendono da una
regione lontanissima dell'amia hanno dei
significati strani a volte per parlare
con uno di loro o le moglie e madre di
loro io devo avere un altro traduttore
che mentre dal cinese mandarino al loro
dialetto e questo è successo per mesi
dentro qualche pallone però vi voglio
restituire una scena questo è tutto
diciamo un backstage rispetto allo
spettacolo per arrivare con la roba che
si può vedere da qualche parte il uno
dei sette la moglie in particolare di un
signore ci ha restituito un'immagine che
mi ha toccato molto e anche la cristina
che è madre di quattro figli e del
regista principale è co autrice del
spettacolo questa l'immagine sua fila
figlia di questo operaio non ha mai
visto il padre se non dallo schermo del
cellulare piuttosto che in un internet
caffè ha visto perché era nato è nata
dopo che il padre è venuto in italia il
padre in dieci anni in italia non è mai
riuscito avere sto benedetto permesso di
soggiorno
nel frattempo vedeva non soltanto che il
padre è diventato con capelli più
bianchi diventava sempre più magro e la
fine l'ultimo giorno si sono accorti che
il tempo che il tempo è finito che il
tempo finito si fa ridere ma il tempo
finito e voglio mandare solo il video
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mare